Yeah, we're live. Hey folks.
Uh, let's fix the chat.
Cool. So,
let's uh make a quick couple of posts.
What on earth is wrong with this?
Now, this is showing my stream, but the
title is wrong.
Okay.
Weird. What on earth is wrong with this?
Now this is showing my
my stream, but the title is wrong.
Okay.
Weird. What on earth is wrong with this?
There we are.
Hello, folks.
Let me figure out how do I download my
own bod.
It should be on YouTube, right?
Yeah, perfect.
Uh
there a download button here.
Download
channel.
Manage videos
live.
RL
upcoming.
Huh?
some went well? 20. Um, I'm trying to
get the VOD so we can get it edited.
Does anybody know what the heck is wrong
with this?
YouTube doesn't I think it does let you
download your own bods, right?
I just don't see the button.
Does it actually not let you download
your own freaking bods?
Wait, hang on. We got to get this to
him. So Weston's going to edit this
together because I goobered it. Um, and
I didn't show the slides.
Why does it not show up? Because I'm
still
live.
Let's see
your channel
I see it here.
Oh, download
download unavailable. What the hell?
the heck.
Oh, is download is this a premium thing
where it's not actually letting you
download it? It's just like
Well, Twitch will let me do it, right?
Here.
Let's try Twitch real quick.
You got a downloader?
Uh, I think I can get you higher quality
though if I give you the VOD, can't I?
Oh my gosh. Where is this content
video producer?
What the heck?
Stream summary.
Reream have it? I might be able to snap
it off a reream.
Let me go grab it off reream. Actually,
Reream saved my last few bots.
landscape video
audio.
Cool. So I will just slap that into a
Google drive once that downloads and uh
as agreed.
Oh and give you the slides as well. So I
will give you
hang on
new folder
X
faster.
That goes there.
And then this goes
here. I upload that to Google Drive.
And in a second, I'll update the other
one. And
how does he know what slide you were on
during the video?
Um, it's pretty obvious like talking
about it.
Like he knows the stuff I'm talking
about as well.
As long as it's pretty close, we're
good.
This is actually way better than hiring
a non-technical editor.
Weston, do I have an email for you? You
can DM me one on Discord so I can share
the uh the Google Drive.
Oh, actually wait. I can just give it
with anyone with the link here.
Anyone link view, it's fine. I got you.
I can just send it to you directly.
Wait, which account? Which account
though? DM me from your whichever
account you're using now though so I
know who
there. There he goes. See if you can
access this. Uh the video is still
uploading. It'll be there in a minute or
two. But see if you can access this.
Now just edit edit like just the
presentation together with the slides.
You can do it like I have my camera here
or however is reasonable. Um
it's basic. Make sure it still gets like
make sure it gets um exported max res
and 100 bucks for editing as agreed.
PayPal or Venmo or whatever is easiest.
Cool.
not too bad of an error since that'll be
sorted out
to have made
and we should be good from here. So for
the folks here for development uh
welcome
we go back to dev
works can see it good. Yeah whenever you
got time to get to it.
breakfast. Yeah, see you around, man.
All right, so what we're going to work
on at the moment, and this is actually a
good spot to have some user feedback.
Um,
so there's a lot of complexity
associated with making the networks at
the moment and some of it's unavoidable
because like the thing that we're doing
here is much more sophisticated than
what Torch is doing.
I'll show you what it looks like.
Yeah. So right now I can clean up the
signatures for this but there's a
rollout buffer there's a train buffer
the rollout buffer has to store any
activations that your network needs um
while you are doing forward passes so
any like intermediate data storage has
to be there and then in training uh
there are also things that need to be
stored so that you can compute gradients
they're additional buffers that need to
be there so that's what the buff train
buffer is and then The encoder itself,
it needs to have uh pointers to all the
different functions that are required
which are forward and backward. That
one's obvious, but then like weight
initialization and then the registration
of all those buffers here.
So
the functions themselves are pretty
simple, right? Like the forward function
is just a maple. The backward function
is a different matt with the grad. The
weight initialization is an orthogonal.
There's a registration of parameters
where you just have to tell it the
shape. Uh the encoder registration here.
This is the shape for the intermediate
buffers. Roll out buffers one
registration. If you look at the actual
code here, there's nothing super
complicated and like I'm going to fix up
the names and stuff so this is not super
long and gross looking. But it's kind of
annoying that you have to define one,
two, three, four, five, six different
functions in order to um just like make
an encoder. And I can't really see any
way around it. Like
it's not like Torch where Torch just
allocates memory all over the place
willy-nilly, right? This is static
memory. So the trade-off of that is you
actually have to allocate the static
memory.
Does this make sense or am I um or is
this just going to confuse the crap out
of everybody?
Also, I can go put dish back on my other
monitor.
I think it makes sense.
I think it's like messy, but I think it
makes sense.
If there's a better way to do it though,
by all means, folks, you can shout me
and I will uh look at it.
And let's ban this bot.
So, other sources of complexity in here.
Um,
Muan update's kind of a mess.
I think these two can get combined,
can't they?
Policy forwards. policy backwards.
I think there's some jank uh right now
with
low precision.
There's some jank with the low precision
that we got to look at.
Uh I don't know. What do you think it
would what do you have? What do you see
it looking like?
So,
uh, the thing with the decoders and
encoders, right, is there's just a ton
of buffers that need to be registered.
And you register everything with the
allocator and then at the end, right,
when everything is registered, then you
also need to like populate the weight
separately.
So you can see like the decoder for
instance, it has the same thing.
There's a forward, there's a backward,
there's a weighted net, there's three
registration functions.
They're individually very simple except
this one because there's continuous
gradient thing here. Um
What are you doing in CUDA or is the CPU
work?
Wait, are you uh I mean the whole nets
are in CUDA.
You see their launch functions are just
inlined.
I'm basically just trying to figure out
what's a sane thing to approach um
a sane way to approach the
mix precision here.
Gradient noise is high.
Very low.
Per parameter is large. Yes.
H
I think this needs to be empirically
ablated, right? Like I can't just go
make these changes and then say, "Ah,
well, okay, you know, they work on
breakout. We need to test this on
minimum 2048.
There's a bunch you can do. YouTube chat
is slow fused gems.
Wait, we don't have mixture of experts,
dude.
This is this is small model
reinforcement learning.
So this is um raw CUDA ultra high
performance like 10 million plus steps
per second training models between
20,000 and 10 million parameters.
Typically our models are like a few
hundred thousand like 200,000 to two
million is most common I would say. Um,
Oh, for the DT type handling like the
approach. Yeah. So, I'm basically I'm
trying to figure out if
Yeah. So, for that
I'm trying to figure out if uh there are
meaningful differences because of our
problem setting and how we should be
handling mixed precision, right? Because
we have pretty small models with big
batches and large updates.
So
there are a lot of places where you
could keep stuff FP32 or put it BF-16.
I don't think there actually is a super
good guideline here other than us like
running training on our hardest problems
and making sure it works. What GPU
architectures? Mostly the consumer
cards. Um most of our experiments run on
like 4090s and 5090s.
just because they're really cost
effective.
We're not at all bound by VRAM. So, the
VRAM is essentially useless to us.
I actually, to be fair, I have not tried
our new optimized code on um the
high-end cards. It could be that with
our new optimizations, everything's
super fast there.
I frankly have no idea.
That'd be kind of cool, honestly.
100 million step per second training.
probably use PTX ISA LD matrix. What?
PTXisa.
Isn't PTX just their um like their
aggregate instructions? Like if you want
to call um raw
like raw tensor core ops
like the thing man is we don't have so
it's a the thing we're doing it's a
little bit different. So like we're not
writing attention ops for instance,
right? Like the core of what we're
optimizing isn't the map mole
cute. Yeah, we are using blasts but like
the thing is we are not so our ops don't
like involve fancy map moles like
attention it's a bunch of fancy map
moles right like most of our kernels
deal with gates and activations.
Um like the actual core compute load is
not attention ops it's just linear
layers.
So those are like really easy just throw
kublass at it. Done.
And then the thing that becomes
difficult is having like we need to
massively massively fuse kernels which
we have. And then we also have this
mixed precision workflow and a bunch of
other stuff around that.
Not using cute.
Um, Rocku Blast has been good.
Element wise, uh, mostly there's a lot
of element wise moles. Yeah, a lot of
elementwise ops in general. There are a
few sequence ops that are not map moles
as well cuz the architecture there are a
bunch of gates and then there's um a
fuse scan like a prefix scan operation.
That's the big fancy um non-MATML
kernel. That's kind of the core of all
of it because it's a mining group based
architecture.
So it's like a simple state space model,
but it has to be super fast
and that's the main thing.
I don't think there's too much I can do
on the optimizer without right now
without risking breaking things because
these are actual like I should probably
have a good version of at least 2048 as
an ablation environment before I do
that.
So okay, other than MU on what other
stuff can we look at
What else is in this file?
Advantage CUDA probably free play cuda
prefix scan kernels
Nvidia the routing kernels
where uh where should I be looking in
here?
Wait, how is routing similar to prefix
scan?
What if this would be similar to um
I don't think We had
I didn't think this had anything like a
prefix scan. Does it?
Is one of these similar?
This is kind of cool.
They just use raw.
Yes, this is cool
like top K isn't it right
a line sum
I don't know which of these you think
would be similar to a prefix scan.
at the very least. This is way less
bloated now.
Grouped top K. Wait, I'm confused. How
on earth is grouped top K? How is this
similar to a prefix scan?
Is there like a merge up that's similar
or something?
Oh, I guess you mean like this stride
operation, I guess.
Scan ops and then use softmax
scan ops.
I mean this is like a log end state
reduce, right? Isn't that what it is?
goal is March 31st.
No, Jess, I like Yeah, if I can get it
by March 31st, I'll be very happy. Um,
the goal is like Yeah, that would be
when I would like to have it done. It's
going to be released when it's released,
though.
There's no way it's like it's not close
at the moment. I'm just I'm working as
much as I possibly can on it. Um,
there is somebody in the uh the Discord.
I I don't know. It's not you, right?
That's like was on um was offering to
optimize I think specifically the fuse
scan. Now, the one thing I'm not sure
about with the fuse scan is the sequence
lengths at which it is uh more effective
to just do a linear op versus to do a
multi-stage reduction.
Yeah. I don't really like the way that
it's it's a bunch of these little
kernels.
Maybe we should just clean this up a
little bit more first. I think it's
still too hard to reason about, right?
Grasshopper.
Yeah. Let me actually
did he reply to my um I asked him like
what specifically the course was
the requirements.
Wait, what's the Discord? I'll go
through repo and let you know. Uh,
discord.gg/puffer.
So, right now, this is the What is this?
This is static native.
Yeah, static native. So basically what
happened here is the latest 40 has the
torch version which is basically all the
same ops and kernels but using torch and
then I've been refactoring it over the
last several days to get rid of torch
because torch wasn't doing anything for
us because it was all just custom
kernels anyways. Um but I've like sort
of made a mess in the process and I have
to clean it up. So, I'm kind of like
stupid LLM for very coarse refactoring
stuff and then I'm trying to manually
I'm going to try to like manually get it
to something that is actually clean and
nice and simpler than the original
Torch. It's just a heck of a process,
right? Cuz Torch imposes a very specific
uh design and it's just completely the
wrong design for Racuda. So, that's what
I'm looking at now.
Major cleanup on chess
outdated. took it from 38. Oh, that's a
nice refactor.
Why 256 threads? You can use way higher
here. Pretty sure.
Uh I go ahead and try it. Like I think
we profiled, but I we might not have. We
do have a profile script.
We have a couple of them. We have like
profile kernels, profile torch.
It should like break down the time spent
in all the kernels.
just at the summit. You gave a
presentation. I want to say it was
incredibly enjoyable. Loved hearing
about your journey. Thank you very much
and welcome. I uh I messed up and I
didn't record the slides correctly for
the talk, but I do have the slides and I
have the talk recording. So, I've sent
it over to one of my contributors and
it'll be up on YouTube uh within a few
days most likely. And aside from that, I
just pretty much stream all of my dev
working on this stuff. Uh currently at
the moment we're trying to figure out
how to make less of a mess of the newly
ported uh torch-free back end where no
torch and it still trains super fast
because
the design of it is quite complex. It is
not that much longer than torch at the
moment but there is some fancy stuff
going on and it's kind of confusing. So,
we're trying to just simplify.
Um,
Yeah, these buffers are going to have to
be void star, aren't they?
histogram check out warp. So the use
case uh profile it's like this, right?
It's it's min group. So you do uh all
the map moles nicely batched for your
entire sequence. So your sequence is
probably going to be something like, you
know, 512
rows of uh 64 each. Like that's a common
sequence pattern. And it's the the scan
op over the 64 DM in time.
Now, we'd like it to scale nicely for
longer, but we can't do it at the price
of making it worse for shorter. Ideally,
it doesn't need multiple paths where
like above a certain length, it needs
multiple like multi-stage reduction. I
don't know.
Are there any obvious bloat packages
apart from torch?
Uh
well, you know, without torch, the core
training code is just CUDA. Like that's
it. It's CUDA and like CUDA uh C like
there's really no other dependency at
all. Um now there is the Python wrapper
but that just has like this little
pretty dashboard for printing stuff and
then the only other non-trivial thing is
the sweeps infrastructure. The sweeps
uses
the sweep still uses torch. I believe
it's like gpy torch or whatever. And uh
that's because we need Gaussian process
models. So presumably we could port that
if we just like the only reason to port
that would just be to get rid of it
completely is to like reduce the package
install cuz
um like that's only ever used for
suggesting hyperparameters. I don't plan
on porting that for 40. That would just
take way way way too long. So the
training back end will be no torch and
we'll keep it for hyperrex.
We could eventually do it,
but I think that's a lot less valuable
at the moment than just like making the
core training super fast and super clean
and um figuring out all the questions
remaining here.
Split finding check the best split
kernels in warp
GBM. Wait, split finding.
That's basically split finding. Is it
so if I recall I'm pretty sure that the
the minor recurrence you can compute it
linearly or you can compute it in like a
log n in log n reductions
um I think those are the two ways you
can do it. Is that the same thing or no?
decoder train buffer.
I think these are going to have to be
void star. Now
Yeah.
Um,
wait. But then
the decoder itself
can't own the weights if we do it that
way.
That's super annoying.
We had O of E by K by B.
We needed the best value. This was
viable back kernels.
Super simple, but they're 3x faster than
LGB.
What is
Okay, I'm not familiar with a lot of the
things you're talking about here. Hang
on.
Light GBM.
Wait, what? Light gradient boost. What?
Now I'm looking up the wrong thing,
right?
Wait, gradient boosting. Wait, how on
how on earth is this in any way
relevant?
Oh, I see. You worked on this and you
had a similar firm. Okay, I see. I see
what you're saying.
I mean, realistically,
man, the kernels probably are not that
complicated for um experienced kernel
devs.
Um I'm actually quite new to um uh to
kernel dev as a whole.
Like it's mostly I got into this for
this update. Um, the idea being that
like, okay, definitely Torch is bloated.
So, if I can as a complete amateur here,
still be making it way way way faster
than Torch, then definitely longer term
that's the way to go because once we get
some contributors that actually know
what they're doing, it'll get way way
faster
though. I don't know. I think at the
moment we do have I think at least a
good 60 70% of the compute is the map
molds. Um, so other than like launch
settings for those,
those are just coup blast.
There is still definitely some room for
optimization though in the kernels
like and still you could get like an
extra 10 20%.
Be useful.
star.
I don't think
got to go. Thank you. And linked up on
GPU mode Discord.
Okay, cool. Thank you.
G PyTorch
I guess would be a contributor PR
probably Jess I mean it would be nice
for being able to ditch the dependency
entirely but it's not going to do much
for speed at all because it's just used
for the hypers sweep.
It's like way way more important to get
the training back end right at the
moment.
force in line and restrict.
We have that on on the actual kernels,
man, don't we?
We have force in line.
What's restrict do?
Pointer is the only way to access
pointer aliasing.
Huh.
Weird.
So what this means that there's no You
don't have a separate handle to this.
Interesting.
Peace.
All right.
I mean, this feels so stupid to have
this many buffers, you know? So, it's
four strus and like what? six functions.
I mean, let's just do the best version
of this I can first
Oh, YouTube ate it. What?
YouTube ate your thing.
Self play for release. Ideally, yeah,
like selfplay for release would be
great, Jess. Once I figured out how to
make this not a mess.
It'll get merged in when it's not crap.
Should be soon
once it's at least as good as the code
that was there in 40, let's say.
I still don't know if this is going to
be good.
six methods. for a one for a module.
That sucks.
We might be able to merge a little of
this though.
this.
Let me think about this in the meantime.
If you can merge these. So, decoder
register params.
Decoder register train. Why can't you do
these at the same time? Because you
might not want to register training and
register params anyways, right?
what about roll out?
Can you do it with a register and roll
out? No, you can't because you only have
to do this one once.
So, this is actually the minimal set.
I it literally it shifts you to auto
accept edits as well. This thing
this one. I don't understand. I think
this one is
the registering par like the append
shapes or whatever.
Okay, that deletes that. So, this was
just LM idiocy. This goes away. We built
the allocator specifically so we
wouldn't have to do this.
So, this struck gets deleted,
which is great.
That function gets deleted. And then
this um this chunk of code here, the
shapes chunk should get deleted as well.
See,
everything gets moved to void star.
the param shapes get deleted as well.
This was the main thing that I hated as
actually. So,
uh why are we storing
no why are we storing this there?
Then minor is going to get the same
treatment probably.
Arguably, we're not even going to need
policy.
I mean,
did he get called once to be fair?
Hopefully we don't break this at the
same time. I mean, the main thing is we
get rid of the weird parameter
registrations
and we we get everything into uh it's
got to be voidstar for the buffers. So,
you can swap in your own version.
Yeah, this is the main thing. I wanted
this gone.
That's the uh that was the goal.
So now those functions are all gone.
We no longer have any weird weight
registration
functions.
offer it own RNG sand.
Okay, this is fine.
These names suck, so we're going to have
to fix those.
signature sock as well.
It's kind of funny how this thing is
like
actually pretty good at checking uses in
a ton of places, but then it's just
completely incapable of designing
anything. Well, I say this completely
screwed it up, right?
Um,
that's easy though, right? We can just
get numl from the pram vector.
All right, be right back. Where's the
restroom?
Hey Ryan,
welcome.
A little annoying to lose numl on the uh
the encoders.
We might want to do something about
that.
getting simpler at least.
rows.
Yes, these buffers need to get
distinguished.
Okay,
this matches before.
Is this not valid? Can you not one line
these?
Oh, wait. You totally
Huh? Can you not do this? Am I stupid?
Is there a thing where you can't do that
with str?
So we actually what we want to do
is this goes
This goes here,
All right.
Okay. Okay. So, the registration
functions have the same six
That would be substantially better at
least.
Oh, this just has a massive ass
signature. Huh?
Okay. Well, I mean, we'll figure that
out.
Standard deviation.
Oh, well, this is cuz the signature is
complete crap. Yeah. Okay. We just
haven't cleaned this up yet. Like, it's
not going to look like this. It's
actually going to end up becoming the
same thing, right?
Yeah,
it's going to end up becoming the same
thing. Cool.
We just haven't cleaned it up yet.
And actually, if we look at the decoder,
what are these things contained in?
speed of puffer comes from bmap plus
async n right in theory
bmap plus async. What happens if the
model prints in jack or tiny grad?
Um, so
in puffer
three, if the training happens, hang on,
let me make sure it's right.
So in puffer three, um, if you spend a
bunch of time writing the
implementation, well,
uh, in Jax, you get about the same speed
and you spend a bunch of time compiling
the code every run. uh if you do it in
tiny you spend slightly less time
compiling the code but it's a bit slower
and uh in compared to puffer 4 if you do
it that way then you just lose 5x speed
it's not just bmap plus async gems
anymore it's the full stack
is slow torch is slow everything is
freaking So,
and actually, in fact, if you just do
the training in Jacks with Puffer, you
can do it if you really want to use RMS.
Um, you're just going to end up with
more complicated code.
How do we get
popped?
It's definitely pulling the wrong stuff
in. Right.
W grab
log std scratch
It's passing it directly instead of
passing the train buffer.
constellation sweep. So, Jess, when we
get to do that, the thing I'm most
looking forward to is like finally just
pinning down and isolating some of the
weird hyperparameter settings um that
end up coming out of sweeps, figuring
out why the heck they happen, and
patching that stuff.
Where's not interested?
Hey, where the [ __ ] is the not
interested button?
why do I get this in my feed just
because somebody in my somebody I follow
comments on it? That's so annoying, man.
Stupid algorithm.
Okay, so then this should be
Yes, this is better, right?
The decoder now takes
let's see the signature.
W grad. What about the encoder?
Encoder as well, right?
Patching things algorithmically. Uh,
most likely. So, yes, Jess,
unless it is a quirk of the sweep, but
it probably is at least some amount
algorithmic.
Okay, this is way better.
So, look now down from having a whole
bunch of unique functions. Oops, that's
not uh let's just Yep. Keep doing that.
Um, so down from having a massive number
of unique types of functions, we have
one, two,
actually, we're going to reorder them.
I think that's not terrible. And then
we'll put the strruct decoder.
is a strct encoder
uh strct decoder.
These go up top. So this is the
interface, right? The interface will be
like this.
because this is not API. So this is
actually not needed.
The comments if anything should go on
the implementations.
The comments go on the implementations,
right?
And then these go
up here
Uh wait this is not API this is so this
actually should get grouped here this is
not API
So that's I mean no longer terrible.
Probably some small renaming and stuff,
right? But that's no longer terrible,
I'd say.
Especially if we just do it like this.
This is too long.
How do you go about algo work? Guess and
check.
I It's not like exactly guess and check,
right? You know, you have an
understanding of the algorithm.
Um, you come up with hypotheses on why
stuff is happening the way it does. You
design experiments to test it. And it's
a lot easier when the experiments are
fast and comprehensive.
Okay, I think this is at least way
better than what we started with. This
is still a chunky thing to have to do to
implement an encoder.
Actually, how many lines is this?
So, we just got it down to
43 lines for the simplest uh the
simplest encoder.
Are sweeps going to take much longer? Of
course, sweeps take much longer than a
single training run. It's linear.
You know, you're going to expect that
sweeps are going to take like 100 plus
times the amount of time. That's why
it's important. Everything is fast.
You compar them. Yeah. 100 lines. So 100
lines for our decoder and our encoder. I
think it's not terrible.
I'm not going to sweep them. Then you're
trolling.
100 * 10 seconds equals 20 some odd
minutes.
So 100 experiments
for like short like environments can
just be done in like 20 minutes.
For complex environments, we'll just run
it on like a 6GPU box overnight. We'll
get a full sweep of several hundred
experiments.
Should I do early stops? Yeah, it's
already included for you in the new
sweeps.
What is this? Assemble decoder. Grab
kernel.
Oh, I think this is cuz the value
function. Yeah, maybe that's not bad.
Hang on a moment.
accident with claw code. The whole
bloody thing is an accident, man.
My justification here is that I'm using
it to fix torch's even dumber code.
Like this is like this is not the code
as I would have written it, right? This
is like incremental refactoring away
from torch. It's not my code until I
actually get it into the form that I
would want to have written if I weren't
constrained um with the original torch.
Alex being there is a little weird.
I think this is fine.
We might just not need a policy, which
would be kind of cool.
and also like the implementation of this
thing needs to be better.
Okay, this is being put back. That was
my code from before that I was like,
where did it go?
Oh, um I think we're actually back to
the size of the file that this was
before I started messing with it. So
that means that this whole refactor was
free.
It's just superior.
Um, not a huge fan of this.
Not a huge fan of this.
It's incremental.
It is getting better.
Network forward function.
Okay. Okay. So, network forward
function.
This does end up with a different sig.
No.
Network forward function like this.
So, what we do is
this goes up because this is going to
end up in a header or whatever. Anyways,
and then this goes
Yeah.
Right. like this. Forward function
backward function.
Forward function encoder backward
function network forward network back.
Yeah, this is good.
type death
this
cut it there
Okay.
So imagine you get this as your header
file
and then you get your standalone your
mod your network and this is your
example code and also not just the
example code also your like high-end
actually solves freaking everything
network.
That seems okay to me.
Um not a big fan of this being a vector.
Oh yeah. Let's make sure we didn't break
it.
Oh, actually these can just be called
encoder decoder network, right?
Yeah, this will be easier than this.
This will actually be very nice.
This one actually gets to take the
types,
which is nice.
hungry. I'm gonna get some food in a
few, but I'll just uh I'll be super
quick.
I'll leave stream on even and just be
right back.
I actually am now the nice thing is I am
seeing how this is going to end up in
relatively clean CUD to see. Uh it's
going to end up being still a few
hundred lines
for the whole policy, but like
it's not even that much more than the uh
original torch code. I guess we do have
the kernels
that are doing a lot of the heavy
lifting, but then again, you're calling
a bunch of kernels when you're using
torch, so whatever.
getting this file today to be nice. I
actually I think that as soon as this
file is nice, I can probably merge this
to 40 and say like we're good. You know,
I'm confident this is the right
direction. Um,
I can merge this to 40
because pretty much until the policy
while the policy code looks like this, I
can't
because I can't ship this.
So, I have to basically be certain that
this can be refactored into shippable
thing.
Weird weird
policy.
Now, what do we have?
Got our mangrove.
All right, I got to go grab uh food. I
will be right back, folks. Few minutes.
who the hell eats peanut butter and
jelly unironically?
see if this builds or if it's used in
policy.
If this is the case, we're actually just
not going to need all these trucks. Huh.
Yeah, we're going to not need all these
trucks, which would be kind of cool.
And also, these deletes are [ __ ]
weird as hell.
Yeah, these are just like disgusting
autos.
Dude, what are all of what is all of
this garbage? Like
why is this done with new as well? Like
it's just bad.
Freaking language models, man. Trying to
C++ify everything.
But I mean, it's still faster. Like I
don't even know why I'm doing this chunk
manually. It would literally be faster
to do this with the stupid model because
of how like messed up the code is.
Like I'm seeing more of them here,
right? This encoder train buffer right
here.
What else would I miss?
And before I did the uh got rid of
torch, it was also like 30 second for
rebuild.
Oops. Actually, let's not come back.
Let's just save some tokens.
Do like this. This will be faster.
I don't think I want to do that. Do I?
I think that's a bad idea.
At least let's not do that right now.
Yeah. So, you can't be casting [ __ ] to
encoder weights, decoder weights like
that, right?
saved input. Yeah,
this is the problem.
So that's probably a bunch of it right
there.
And my stream title is still wrong, by
the way. just didn't update correctly.
Wait. Decoder backward function.
It takes weights
train buffer
value
red input.
Interesting. Okay.
Why didn't you even want to do this in
the first place?
How comes the model struggles to learn
and other times it learns very fast?
Struggles to learn and other times
Um
so local minima don't exist in weight
space in the way that you're thinking of
in policy space they do because
these these or strategy space rather
because strategy space is low
dimensional.
So like yes they can just like not
figure out what is the next thing to do
to advance in sparse environments.
Yeah, this is why I actually have to be
like looking at this because it does see
it just started trying to add stuff to
the API that's completely redundant for
no reason at all.
Ask the model to explore more.
You can't like
well what's your environment like how
fancy is it?
Because there's it's a very different
answer, right? If you're asking like how
do I solve Flappy Bird versus how do I
solve I don't know Neural MOO 3
Lights Out game. What is that?
Oh, wait. Isn't this the um isn't this
the freaking clue scroll thing in
Runescape?
5x5 got all fast. Yeah, expected.
What's the reward?
final rewards.
Huh?
Well, I think you just have terrible
rewards then.
number of life. Yeah, why don't you
literally just give it a reward of plus2
for every light that it turns off and
minus.2 for every light that it turns
on.
It needs to open more lights and
intermediate steps. That's fine.
You're randomizing the puzzle start,
right?
It also has a time. It should have a
timeout. Like if it fails the puzzle
after a certain number of steps, uh you
should just reset the end and give it a
negative one.
Or just Yeah.
How are we doing this right now? Oh,
we're cheating with the cast, aren't we?
Oh, are we? Wait, are we cheating with
the casts?
Decoder forward.
Encoder forward. Matt mall.
Uh, yeah, we're cheating with the Ford.
I hate that.
Well, now we got to think about that
thing. Lovely.
Well, you can't freaking do this either.
The shapes. No.
I think this could work. Save this one
strct.
Tiny tiny amount of wasted CPU memory.
CPU memory. That should not matter.
And then you have one freaking thing.
Yeah.
All right. Cool. I hate puzzles.
I have RL agents to solve puzzles.
I am absolutely terrible at all puzzles.
Thinking hard. Me lift big rock.
If we just end up with a weight struck
and activation struck. That's actually
that is super clean.
Oh, technically
there's one other way we could do it.
Now, this should not be casting.
Where's the casts?
Okay, good. This is no longer casting
in here.
We have a much shorter policy function.
Good.
can actually see what the hell going on
Now
presumably this is bloated.
We can't freaking see it though until we
um clean it up a little bit.
just like one lined a bunch of crap
there.
Yeah, it's just one line. Way too much
crap.
Including this. Let's start with this up
here though.
Let's see what's going on with Mr.
I don't know if we're going to want to
keep it like this. Um, the other option
is that we have
we could end up with like two separate
buffers dep like depending
installing Da Vinci on Abuntu.
Hey, Weston. How are you going, man?
need to give you some better hardware,
man. Like we're doing all this research
and stuff.
I got to go. Like I guess I could put
some bounties up on Puffer.
The thing is I've got to get um it's
always like so in flux with 40.
Maybe once it's stable, we'll assign
like a dollar amount to specific things.
Okay, this is exact same as before.
We are happy.
600 bucks because of the freaking RAM.
Jesus.
Is it still cheaper to build them, man?
Like some of the pre-builts get better
deals on that stuff and don't get
scalped on RAM.
They can raise the prices on pre-builts.
Yeah, they don't always though. In the
same time,
like 10 years ago, it used to be the
case that you always would build your
own things as the margins were just
nuts. Uh nowadays, it actually kind of
depends.
It is probably still generally cheaper
if you really want to hunt around. Um, I
don't do that anymore, of course.
Why the hell's this got to be back
there? Huh?
Looking forward to seeing the slides as
well. Yeah, Weston's editing it for me.
5090 alone or 3 to 4K. Yeah, freaking
ridiculous, man.
I'm going to go check out the pre-builts
pretty soon and see if we can order
some. But if they're going to be that
price, like no thanks.
It's not right.
Sold out. Yeah.
I mean, if I can get them for 5 to 6K,
I'd be happy with that. I'm not paying
7K a desktop.
They're upping the prices at 5090s to
5K.
What makes a good environment? You see
TW 2048 breakouts obviously the
canonical example. So um our breakout
has been historically for us the
simplest fastest environment that is
still broadly indicative of performance.
So if you use pong, pong is too simple.
Anything solves pong. So something Oh,
this solves pong fast. That means
nothing. Um, breakout typically if your
thing works there, there's a decent
chance it works everywhere. Uh, if it
works on 2048, it's almost guaranteed
that it works everywhere. And if it
works on neural MMO 3, then it
definitely works everywhere.
It's not you know it when you see it. So
like 2048 had a it was a very well
scalable task, right? Where you
basically you could pour a lot more
computed than you'd expect and you kept
getting better results.
Um
it just like was a very very hard
scaling task.
Those tend to be likewise
uh better transferable
when you have an enemy that you just
insta solve in 10 seconds. Sometimes it
transfers, sometimes it doesn't.
We have some that we trust more than
others because we've used them before
and you know the results have or have
not transferred.
Freaking scam alone just sitting on all
the RAM.
Whatever
D70 Ti
that Omen is still a great buy. I
literally So what I did the uh what I
did relatively recently,
I literally just did this. Click click.
Where is it?
Uh there.
I think this is actually gone up a
couple hundred bucks.
I think I got something around this.
Oh, they have laptops as well now.
Might end up getting one of those
eventually. We'll see.
My laptop sucks at the moment.
I'm sick of buying the Razer ones. They
just they keep screwing stuff up on
their QA.
Pokemon Showdown being built. Difficulty
with using a potential benchmark
complexity correctness of the end. Yeah,
pretty much just have to get like the
thing implemented fully tested fast.
It's big engineering project, right?
I think we either split this to be mini
brew layer or we just have it joint.
Let's I guess look at the logic for
that.
If done properly, do you think it would
make a good benchmark? Of course. It's a
little tough because you need um
selfplay to really get good results and
selfplay is still hard. Otherwise, you
need to have like a good scripted
baseline.
If people made like decent, fast
heristic scripted baselines, it would be
really freaking good. Um, even without
that, it would still be like pretty darn
useful. The only thing I got to make
sure is I don't get sued by Nintendo
over the assets. So, we got to be
careful about what we like where we do
that or how those get hosted or pulled
from. I don't know if we just hook it up
to an existing front end and just have
the sim code or whatever.
intent don't. Yeah, exactly.
I remember I went to GDC to like talk to
game devs about uh different game
companies about RL and pretty much
everyone there was chill and would talk
to me except Nintendo.
You know, you had like Epic there, you
had Riot there, you had like all these
awesome companies and then like for
whatever reason Nintendo's there just
like thinking they're the [ __ ] and
they're like, "Oh no, we have no one to
talk to you. is a technical whatever or
whatever the [ __ ] It's like uh we do we
have we have interviews only. It's like
okay. Yeah. Okay. You don't bring
business development people to the
conference. Oh,
copy.
Hang on. This is
x
That's actually a very heavy markup. I
honestly I think that a lot of these uh
pre-built companies, they've sort of
like taken advantage of the volatility
or maybe they're just increasing their
margins because they want to hedge
against the volatility.
Either way, you can like you can blame
that directly on Altman
because how protective are their IP?
Uh yeah, Nintendo's just like lost happy
for whatever reason.
It's kind of funny like there are few of
the bigger companies that are actually
really chill and they like when people
do cool stuff around their games and
Nintendo's just like you drew Pikachu
get sued.
They had this whole thing where they
were like trying to ban Twitch streamers
from playing emulated versions of their
games. They're just like, "Oh no, you
have to stream it on a freaking original
Game Boy." It's just like, are you
[ __ ] me?
But nope.
They also like don't want people doing
ROM hacks as well. They think like doing
ROM hacks is uh is like the same as
stealing the game or whatever. I don't
even know. They're nuts.
I don't know what the hell's wrong with
their legal as well because like I mean
Nintendo's been such an awesome company
for the stuff they've produced over so
so so many years.
They're legal is just nuts.
Dude, you can't just like Yeah, you
can't play our games in public. Like,
what? No.
The biggest thing that they ever got me
on. This is ridiculous. Um,
yeah. This is the most ridiculous thing
they ever got me on.
And the reason for this was this was my
favorite uh this was my favorite growing
up. And I was like always sad that they
never made a big one. And then you know
in my mid20s they made a big one. So
damn it, I'm buying it.
Oh, is it just cuz we don't have a batch
map?
I watched the Opus stream. The original
one was so dumb and brain dead. Dude,
I'm not doing anything remotely like
that. Did you do the puffer fish
animations? know I hired um a couple
actually different artists and I'm
actually going to be hiring um I'm going
to be hiring more artists for the puffer
fish uh quite soon.
I'm a split. The heck?
No, I hate that.
buffer is getting uh it's going to look
very similar just streamlined and better
for doing more animations.
PR for lights out. Awesome. I will get
to that. Keep reminding me if I don't
because
I've been kind of grinding this thing
lately. What do we got here?
It's a really shitty CPU cooler, isn't
it?
A 9950X with this cooler. Really?
I do actually recommend air coolers
these days now because I've just like
I'm sick of dealing with um
the all-in- ones, but
not super cheap air coolers.
So, this now no longer looks awful,
right?
RL checklist, uh, reinforcement. Uh,
it's in there as well as I think there's
also one on the website. The quick start
guide just like walks you through
everything and links you to everything.
Oh, wait. The rein the quick start guide
or the Yeah, that one I think has most
of it.
Does it? It might just be on the
website. I don't remember.
I mean, literally just doing this will
catch most of it. Um,
just literally doing this will get most
of your stuff on the website.
Can somebody explain to me what's going
on with this live? Hi, I'm Joseph. I am
an RL researcher. I stream all of my
research. I build very very high
performance training, inference,
um, custom architectures, custom
simulation,
and I stream all of my dev. We've got
demos at puffer.ai.
I am currently refactoring our new
backend, which trains at 10 million plus
steps per second without even needing
torch, just in raw CUDA. And I'm going
to try to make this thing simpler and
easier to use than even Torch.
I've got it decently simple,
but um there's still quite a little bit
of bloat around with this.
I don't like the way that we're handling
MR activation buffers.
I don't like this loop.
I don't like all this indexing.
I like these assigns.
Fuse scan not taking the prefix buffers.
Jank.
Yeah. Okay. We'll do that next.
Let me grab a quick refill on my tea.
I'll be back in a couple minutes. And
then what we're going to do is we're
going to see if we can unjankify the min
layers. And once we get this thing down
to something more manageable,
policy will be very easy from there to
fix up.
And then it'll end up being like 300
lines worth of stuff outside the kernels
total for the whole network, which will
be great. I'll be right back.
Okay,
I'm back.
Let's take a look at this prefix scan.
This has a star vows, right?
So, isn't this supposed to just take the
prefix scan?
It really should, shouldn't it?
That's the whole point of it.
You did it.
What?
You got it exported or what?
Download the pod. I did. I sent you the
drive link command, didn't I?
I'm good at it. 1080p, right?
We should be able to get 1080 out of it.
VOD isn't there. You sent the M4A.
Um, let me double check.
Why did it not upload, dude?
You're right. I don't know why. Hang on.
Let me know in two minutes if it's not
there.
Okay, cool. I got I got to reply to this
guy in a bit, but um
you got a cool course project.
Please reply.
Can you wait? Hang on. Can you please
tell us what's the purpose of your RL or
research? Uh please reply. Yeah. So I
build very high performance
reinforcement learning tools. My work is
really a like overarching and general
attempt to fix the things that I think
are wrong with the field. Um as of when
I started it, it was mainly experiments
being so slow that people were running
in proper and insufficient experiments
and results were mostly invalid. The
vast majority of papers did not actually
transfer to other similar complexity
problems. they were incredibly tuned and
overfitted. There's a complete lack of
complex and interesting environments for
training and evaluation. Um people
weren't actually then taking these tools
and trying them on real problems in the
real world.
uh the literature itself basically made
it impossible to make a real progress on
the algorithms because for anything that
you would try there would be a ton of
algorithms out there that claim to solve
the problem that don't work in practice
and that use benchmarks that are too
slow for you to evaluate on yourself. So
it was a ton a ton a ton of different
things and the goal of Puffer is to just
be a ludicrously fast and simple
platform for doing all sorts of RL
research. We do our own environments now
so that there are fast environments from
very simple to very complex for
evaluation. We do our own algorithms
research around them as well. We pull in
some things from the literature. But uh
me being graduated, I'm no longer
constrained to be evaluating against
papers that I know actually don't work
in practice and like you know trying to
run evals on slow environments where
it's virtually impossible to do. So it's
really an overarching effort. Um we have
a ton a ton of people now that have
gotten involved with this through the
open source. Uh we have this working on
some real problems as well and the
methods are improving too. What I'm
doing at the moment is I'm really really
trying to understand uh what is the
actual hardware limitation like what is
the actual cap speed that we can get
where are we wasting all of our compute
in RL um you know what is the realistic
limit of how far we can push performance
and to do that we're doing our own
low-level backend uh this is really nice
for letting us play with different
architectures at the actual speed that
they are capable of running this lets us
cross evaluate different things much
better. And honestly, this is in many
ways like there are things that are
difficult to work with here, but there
are more reasonable things than the
difficulties I've had working with torch
before. And we're already getting a lot
of mileage out of this. So, the next
update to Puffer 4 is mainly going to be
this super fast raw CUDA back end as
well as some tools for large scale uh
experimental analysis and a bunch of new
things with that. That's kind of the
gist of what we're doing at the moment.
And why did the why is the um
do I keep like closing it before it
updates or it uploads
here? Listen, let me try one last time.
Something's screwy with it.
Can we do customized algorithms? Yeah,
of course.
Why not?
How do you think I changed the
algorithm?
What Puffer isn't going to do though,
right, is we're not going to be a
library of every algorithm out there
that doesn't actually even work.
That's the problem is most libraries
they focus on just trying to implement
every algorithm. Uh the algorithms don't
even work and they're super slow. So
what's the point?
that is sketchy.
Yeah, that is sketchy I think.
this is probably better lay memory
layout the way we have it.
Yeah, it's probably better this way.
So then it's just a matter of like why
is it still looks kind of janky? Okay.
But then the prefix scan buffers kind of
make sense the way they are now.
There
I'm trying to figure out what I don't
like about this. Let's see. State of I
Yeah, this feels like this feels super
redundant now.
and then the scan buffs is like weird,
right?
and the scan buffer should just be the
same size.
Something like this, right? B T H at the
minimum,
Okay, that's looking at least somewhat
better, right?
Not absolutely horrifying.
Why are we overwriting grad
and returning grad
It is the same, isn't it?
A grad input buff.
Try this. I don't know if that's the
same
instance here. It's been demoted to be
slightly smaller.
Ah, so this breaks it. Hang on.
Brad equals
Oops.
Am I being dumb here
or is this not the same thing?
transfer fully scrambled 8 by8. There
you go.
Was that um
did the new rewards help or did you do
something else?
Right.
We do it like this.
Is that what you did though? Like for
the reward?
It'll be a nice end.
That's kind of cool because that's
already tough for me to do.
Like I can't freaking do that easily at
all. I mean, there's an algorithm I
could learn, I'm sure. But
that's very nice.
That'll be a cool little demo. And
now the real question is, did you make
the lights puffers?
We could. Yes, you could. That's how you
get me more excited about merging the
end quicker.
yeah, otherwise you got to resize the
tensor every time. So I think this is
fine.
On graphs next
Hey, look at this. What on earth?
What the heck?
Uh, I see this is the flatten. Huh?
Yeah, this is the flatten.
Okay, that's actually a pretty simple
uh forward function, isn't it?
Having the normal game is fine. You'll
make it too darn complicated for
anybody. Like the thing about making
really hard ends that people can't
understand is they don't appreciate that
they're actually interesting.
which C++ doesn't allow assignment to
erase.
So basically it's like just keep it how
it is now.
I don't know what is. I don't know. Hey,
what's up?
I wish there were a cleaner way to do
this, you know?
You need to be able to reassign shape.
has your work on the pub report provided
any insights into ML beyond
meta is silly and brothers are silly
curious if low level provided you with
any unique insights
Um,
well, I mean, yeah, like the inside of
we're kind of going to be able to
steamroll much harder problems with very
very little hardware.
Additionally, this just brings us this
brings the architecture design closer to
the hardware. So, we actually get to
think about like what ops are
computationally efficient and we get to
test that much more cleanly.
I honestly think that there's a huge
mistake at the moment and that you
mostly have a lot of researchers who
don't know how a GPU works writing ops
that are horribly slow that are like
better in um you know better in samples
or whatever and they're just crap.
It's like very uncontrolled experiments.
Oh yeah, that is a lot simpler, isn't
it?
Okay, you probably want to squeeze off
Steam roll light mode.
Imagine that with four.
Yeah.
Okay. policy is way cleaner
Yeah, this is better.
We're about the same amount of code as
well
I see
it's actually that view op
Is this the next thing to refactor?
It is, right?
So, let's look at our code. Let's see
what's still a mess.
Tensor's gotten a little chunky.
This isn't bad.
Bad.
Matt moles.
Orthogonal is a mass, but we don't even
know we need it.
We've got a couple additional matrix
ops.
a couple uh tensor ops that we don't
know if we need or not.
They're like not too too bad.
There's your main PPO loss.
So, we do have a bunch of stuff up here.
But then from here,
it's only
220. Was it 300 lines?
Not bad.
Um,
yeah. Okay, that's not bad.
Do we try to get different encoders
working?
50% of knowledgebased work could become
obsolete in 3 to 5 years.
Um yeah, so I have a very very low
opinion of anthropic in general.
I know that's despite using flawed at
the moment. It's just it's not so on
their technicals. It's more so that
they're just incredibly incredibly out
of touch.
And like the thing is, okay, which 50%?
like the 50% that's basically useless
already.
Exactly. So like when you say 50%
it's like people say wow 50% of
knowledge based work it's like it's like
okay well if you're going to say in my
view like 50% of the work is already
useless right so if you're just looking
for an excuse to fire the people who are
basically useless anyways then maybe
this gives you an excuse or whatever
maybe but like that's not what they mean
and I don't like anthropic in general
they're very very out of
like anthropic was actually just the
nuttiest and most out of touch people
leaving Open AAI to go form their own
thing.
I remember some conversations with some
of the people that like joined very
early and they were just batshit.
So, I don't think I'm going to take any
of their grand standing like seriously.
One bit.
Dario's bion. Abso [ __ ] lutely.
Absolutely.
I will say though that having read um
his latest uh essay, I I don't think
he's intentionally doing this. I think
that he thinks he's doing the right
thing.
Cute.
Yeah, I think he's just like SCPed
himself on that one.
I don't know.
my general read at the moment, and who
the hell knows, I could be wrong, but I
think Demis is a genius and is not
ranstanding about freaking everything
and is mostly like still doing a ton of
other things with AI. It's not just
throw the LLM at it and hope it solves
everything.
Um,
I think Dario thinks he's doing the
right thing, but is nuts
and Alman is just knowingly lying.
Does that cover everybody I could
possibly piss off?
I think just about
any guess William is up to. Not too
much, Jess. But
from his interview
seems like he is thinking about things
that are very far out there, not just
like a little bit different from what
people are doing at the moment. And if
that's the case, I hope so because uh we
need more of that.
Proof of that's right in here in front
of you. Like I could not be able to just
Yeah, let's make RL 10,000x faster. Like
you're not supposed to be able to make
10,000 extra improvements. Only happens
when people are just hard hard trolling.
I mean, it's kind of cool in some sense
because like if I couldn't be making
these major advancements, then I would
be motivated to work as hard as I do and
I'd probably just do something else. But
it's still like ridiculous.
Elon.
Um,
I mean, I think he is actually for the
most part being honest with everything.
I think he's just newer to
he's like doing too much stuff and he's
messing up some of the technicals
um on the decisions.
I mean, I'd way rather see him in charge
than Alman or um
uh whatchamacallman or
Dario.
I also think that their edge focus is
something that I really wish DeepMind
had. Um, that's like the fatal flaw of
Deep Mind is they just they do too much
math when the answer is engineering.
Like they've only got one tool in their
toolkit and bash the thing with math
until it falls over.
Still quite a bit of stuff to clean up
here, isn't there?
Um,
see, I want to clean up Mulan, but I
don't know how much we can until we fix
the rest of the stuff.
Max engineering.
So, I definitely I definitely like am
very low on the math side.
But I do think that if I saw something
where it's very clearly like look this
is a math problem not an engineering
problem I would take the time to go
after it. Um state space models actually
were kind of like this where I guess
this is like really simple for math
people but for me the prefix scan stuff
is really unintuitive and nonobvious.
So going in on an architecture like this
that it was really confusing to me like
that's one example of okay maybe we need
some math.
Muan is another example. Mulan was
awesome. It just doesn't happen as often
as it as is the case that you just
needed to build this stuff to not be
crap.
I'm just suggesting to open source
contributing for large programs, but
probably just start.
I mean, I have an RL guide out there,
right? It's the This is literally how
people get started with my stuff at the
very least. I've made it pretty easy.
You don't start by doing this crap that
you see me doing here, for sure, because
I barely know what I'm doing with this.
That's why it's like open-ended. Um,
this guide will walk you through much
more gently in a way that will get you
building stuff pretty much immediately
and fill in gaps with uh what I think
are the most useful papers along the
way. That's what I would suggest.
The only thing that I don't know what
the damn allocator is.
Wait a second. Wait,
we don't need the vector, do we?
Puff tensor shape.
referenced that before. It's really all
my best advice in one place. That and
the programming and ML guide if you're
newer overall.
But a master's thesis in RL. Any advice?
Um
maybe NYU
Eugene's lab. We work with them on
driving, like autonomous driving, they
do a lot of sim heavy RL work.
Uh, other than that, if you're in the
UK, Jacob Forers's lab, I don't know if
they do masters. They probably do. They
probably do, right? I don't know how it
works in the UK.
Uh, transportation, there's Kathy Woo's
lab.
Pulkit at MIT does a little bit of RL
sometimes.
uh robotics, you know, there's Berkeley,
all those labs.
There's a little bit of CMU as well.
Uh what's his name? Russ. Russ, I think,
still does some RL.
Those are the ones that come to mind.
Oh yeah, there is some at Stanford, but
not too much. Chelsea Finn. Chelsea
Finn. Yeah,
some I haven't really seen her work. I
don't know about I haven't actually seen
much of her work, so I don't know if I
say that yet.
I think there is a way to do this. I'm
not fully seeing it,
Problem is it has to get assigned to
what? Cryobuffers.
It's kind of weird. I think about it for
a second. Let me use the restroom. I'll
be back in a a second.
All right, I figured it out. I think I
got a good solution. Do you ever run
hyperparameter sweeps, by the way, or is
that silly tinkering? You did not just
ask me that, dude.
All right, I got to show this. This is
ridiculous. How on earth can we not
possibly
You see this article? I spent months
coming up with the best hyperparameter
sweep algorithm out there, building the
best hyperparameter sweep infrastructure
in RL uh and making ridiculously
comprehensive results, running tens of
thousands of experiments. We always run
hyperparameter sweeps. If you're not
running hyperparameter sweeps, you are
trolling.
You're not doing real research.
Exception being if Puffer is so good, it
just solves it out of the box and you
go, "Okay, problem's done.
All right. So, here's the uh the cool
fix that we've got to make this
registration stuff not suck.
running one right now. Feels like I'm
overfitting on the solve problem.
So, I was thinking I was doing something
wrong. I'll read the article though.
Yeah. So, the point of hyper sweeps is
to know that you're not failing because
your hypers suck. In RL, you are very
often failing because your hypers suck.
Now, let it be known, right, that as
Puffer has gotten better, we've gotten
more stable so that our defaults have
been generally good for a wide range of
problems. Um, but hypers are still like
top. It's either hypers or sim bug.
Those are the two biggest errors. If
your sim is correct, then it's not
learning. It's probably your hypers.
And sim includes having like some sort
of at least remotely sane reward
structure.
You have YouTube vids on some of the
slides. Would you like me to download
them and insert them instead of having
them on a slide? Yeah, that would work.
Question. You can like request access to
anything that you don't have.
I mean, if you like whatever, as long as
they move and like you have the video in
some capacity at a reasonable
resolution,
you don't have to go too crazy. Just do
something that's like relatively quick
for you, you know?
We were told today that Puffer's
default.
Wait, when did I say that?
We were told today Puffer's default pars
were good for 99%
of use cases.
Uh, yeah, that's not true. on simple
problems that look similar maybe,
but like so the like puffer being good
mo like almost all the time, it includes
you running a sweep,
but like the point is the sweeps are
super fast, right?
Drone. Oh, well I mean the thing is that
in their case like you got to realize
that they are doing variations of a
drone problem. So once they have their
default hypers for a drone like most of
the changes they make to their end like
they won't have to retune the hypers.
Does that make sense? So like around in
a specific problem once you have decent
hypers like you have to make quite a
substantial change to it before your
hypers are completely invalidated. But
if you try to take the drone params and
use them on like checkers or something,
that's a very different problem. It
could end up being very different. But
it's automated for you, right? Sweeps
are part of our standard tooling.
Uh,
you can just, you know what you can do,
Wes? You can put it the full size. You
can put my stream the full size and just
like overlay my cam on top of it.
That'll be better. You can like flip it
if any of the slides are horribly
horribly obstructed. And then you can
make my cam a little bit bigger if you
have the resolution.
So just like keep the video the full
size. My cam like here basically this
right
order where is it? Send to back
bottom and then like this.
Like this. Something like this. Yeah.
Good.
If that's easy enough to do.
Uhhuh.
And
I got to go to dinner fairly soon as
well. I just want to get this pattern
in.
The one thing I don't like is you dip
the lines.
I like the um the single line register
like this. It's very nice.
Like this is pretty nice here, right?
This is just destructing it. Uh,
but then I don't like that you have to
have this down here.
So, this will add lines, but it's in the
good surface of this
Maybe I should line up the shapes. You
never know. I don't usually do that, but
maybe this is the time to do it.
But what then? The uh the the nice thing
about this, it's the allocator that gets
better, right?
Yeah. The allocator is way better like
this. way better.
This is like actually a not total crap
piece of code.
Can you please explain in layman terms
what you are doing that will cause that
much of improvement? So, um, the title,
oh, that's probably why we have all the
viewers. The title is from the talk that
I just, uh, I gave a while ago. The
stream title did an update. So, um, we
already have made RL 10,000 times
faster. Like, yeah, that's what Puffer
Lib does. Um, we rewrote the entire
stack of reinforcement learning over the
last two plus years and everything from
uh multipprocessing to the environment
to now the entirety of training down to
replacing torch completely and custom
kernels like everything has been
rewritten for Perf. So it's not just one
thing.
Now, uh, if you want to get from like
the speed that people were at to like
10x faster, all you needed to do was fix
the really bad multipprocessing backends
and increase some batch sizes. If you
wanted to get to like a thousand times
faster, you needed to do that and also
move the environments into memory
optimize C. And then from there, that's
when you had to start actually looking
at architecture modifications and um,
replacing some of the slow stuff that
Torch does.
You can check out the demos on puffer.ai
if you haven't seen them. Do feed the
puffer star on GitHub. Helps me out a
ton and it's free. Um, yeah, we can
train these environments at well over 10
million steps per second now. most of
them
asked when to apply RL and I wrote down
it was good at solving fiddly
optimization problems expanding on this
I didn't write down it's like fiddly
unintuitive optimization problems uh
control is a great example of this right
control is a fiddly unintuitive
optimization problem uh mechanics in
games like if you think of mechanical
control in games it is a fiddly
unintuitive optimization problem a lot
of industrial sims where it's really
hard to write scripted policies, fiddly,
unintuitive optimization problems,
right? Like anything where it's like,
well, I can't really describe this
problem well in natural language. It's
not really super visual. It's just like
a bunch of states that got to get mapped
to actions and we don't really have a
good way of doing it. I don't know. We
could come up with some heruristics, but
that's really tough. Maybe we can do
search. Maybe it's really hard to do
search because it's too big of a space.
Reinforcement learning. And the only
caveat is it also has to be fast to
simulate. But often times, even if it
isn't fast to simulate, you can make it
fast to simulate. And people just
haven't bothered making the sim fast.
For instance, if you want to write a
really good simulator for depression,
all you have to do is write all your
code through this piece of crap all day.
I'm looking
very much forward to uh
not reinforcing mment learning myself
with this crap and uh getting back to
writing my code manually. But alas, the
torch code was so bad that there's so
many refactor ops before it gets back
into that shape is going to be a little
bit.
Let's see if this broke all my code
horribly in the process of doing that.
Oh, lovely.
is that M I L P.
I've never seen that acronym.
Oh, mixed integer linear. Yep. Okay. So,
uh if you want to do a whole bunch of
fancy math. Yeah, a lot of things can be
framed as convex opt. If you can do it
and you're smart, then go ahead. Um if
you can't do it or if you're not smart
enough to do that, then you can do some
RL.
And you better the other thing is it
better actually be a mixed integer
problem. it better not be something that
you're modeling as one where that's the
suboptimal solution right because if
you're just modeling something as that
right then RL will do better
how are they different from regular deep
learning uh well a lot of things you
have a simulator in the loop so
supervised learning by comparison is so
easy to write infrastructure for you
don't have to run simulations in the
loop, right? Um, that's like the major
major source of stuff being hard. The
second major source of stuff being hard
is that the networks are small. There
are two things that are hard in a deep
learning info, right? It's optimizing
stuff for small networks and optimizing
stuff for large networks. Medium-sized
networks are really easy.
Also, if you're talking about like
supervised learning, as in language
modeling, for instance, they're
basically solving one big problem. So,
they don't have stuff like horrific
hyperparameter jank that they have to
retune constantly per problem. Um, a lot
of things that we have to deal with,
they just don't exist over there.
I don't I started off in NLP.
If you want to see my first paper, which
not exactly amazing work
I think I have the code. The code wasn't
even that bad.
I wouldn't exactly use it as a
reference.
Probably that one's like 19,
maybe younger.
Please don't have broken.
Oh, you broke all of my code.
Let me see in the meantime if this even
makes sense though.
I think this syntax is kind of fine.
This sucks, doesn't it? That you have to
do these separately.
I could also do register over an entire
buffer at once. So it would be horribly
janky to do it that way.
Anybody have thoughts?
So the thing is you need to specify the
size of your tensor and uh you also need
to be able to register the tensor.
because the allocator needs to know the
size of it
because we're doing all of our
allocations in static memory.
I guess we could technically
we could make the allocator eager and
then like reallocate or whatever or have
a max size.
I don't think that was the bug. Might
have been. And I didn't think that was
the bug. I could have forgotten to
rebuild.
Numerically identical. Good.
Um
Well, let's look at the allocator
itself. At least this is better now.
I mean all that this is doing is storing
all the tensors and then when you call
create it's just malicking everything
right
The only thing I don't like is that
being a vector, but like um you know
whatever,
Other than just using a vector, I don't
have any complaints about the allocator
really.
This I don't like. I don't like that you
have to separately create and register
Let's see if it comes up with anything.
I can't really think of much here other
than
I mean we could do like a dot register
on the tensor
Oh yeah, that's a really jank. That's
the thing that I was saying before that
I could do it once for this dropped, but
it would be really sketch.
If I do that, I know a user is going to
hit it and they're going to spend three
days on it. So like, I'm not doing that.
I already have one place in the code
where that's basically unavoidable
and I don't like doing it that way.
I mean, basically the only thing that I
um the thing that I'm fighting here,
there'd be several ways to do it. If I
could just pass
um
if I could just use this syntax
anywhere other than in a strruct, I'd be
fine, right?
Don't fight C.
What's the C way to do this?
That is so like this is really clean
right here. I mean arguably I don't know
if I want to do like this right and like
line them all up or whatever
like you could.
I don't know if I want to or not, but
like either way, this is super super
clean. And then the format's like a
matter of I mean, we'll figure it out.
But just being able to do your whole
strct like this and like, "Hey, here are
your tensors.
I'm not seeing many alternatives and I
got to go to dinner soon. Anybody seeing
anything?
If I'm not calling this in the function,
does it do anything else?
Going to head out. Thank you.
Thanks for stopping by. Hope you enjoyed
Star the Puffer helps out a lot.
Wonder if anybody did anybody go Star
the Puffer after the talk.
Do we get some puffer stars? 50 65
some stars
need the puffer.
I mean, come on. There's got to be a
better way to do this. No. So,
the shape initializations are very, very
nice.
I could do the brittle thing.
That's so bad though, isn't it?
Um, stop
equals
So the oneline version before was
initializer list based. So I'm thinking
like oh that looked nice but no that was
the gross initializer list thing.
Well at least we know now that like if I
want to go that way I can.
This is the C way to do it here, isn't
it?
is you just write slightly more C code,
but you write very simple C
Okay. Well,
failure on line count from that
win on simplicity failure on line count.
The problem is you can freaking like you
can forget to register. No, but if you
forget to register the thing, it'll just
like hard crash on it and it's a very
easy to fix error. That's the thing.
Some of these things need to get updated
a little bit.
Like I don't want to do star a equals.
I'd rather just make it here, right?
Okay. So, if we're going to say this is
reasonable at least,
but it's so much freaking code.
It's so much freaking code.
You can do it so easily with the stupid
initializer. That's just the thing as
well.
But well, it adds a layer of
indirection. So I actually don't even
think that's good.
Yeah, actually it's not even good to do
it that way, is it?
Can you give me edit perm so I can see
properties of image?
Yes.
Uh do not break my presentation please.
In case I need to give this again
I will give you a link.
Gotcha.
Cool.
I am I'm going to go get dinner folks.
Thank you for tuning in today.
I might stream some more later,
but I kind of need some rest. I've been
doing this a lot lately.
I mean, I'd say this was decent
progress, though. Like,
we didn't really shorten the code, but
it's a hell of a lot simpler.
This is approaching something that I
think is reasonably shippable. I'm not
super happy with the registration stuff
quite yet. Um,
obviously like Muan's a mess still. I
think a couple like the think the loss
function is still a mess, but this is
getting to something decent.
I do really want to figure out how we
can just make it shorter, though.
I'm going to think about this over
dinner, this registration stuff.
I'm going to think about if there's a
good way to do this. I'd really, really
like to not have the C++ crap in here.
So, I'll think about it. Um, for folks
who tuned in, thank you very much for
your interest. If you want to support my
work for absolutely free, feed the puff
or star on GitHub. It really does help
out. Um, you can join us on Discord if
you want to get involved with
development. You can follow me on X for
more reinforcement learning content.